the Joe Rogan experience Mexican food
too will pack on the pounds if you look
into some calorie dense food row there's
a place up here what is that place on
Canoga where is that place that Mexican
joy my soul have been assaults on the
best places this is one little join you
want to say the name because I don't
want them to get flooded oh don't be so
good dude so good and so authentic you
going again the Mexican soap operas are
playing now freak out pickled jalapeno
freak the [ __ ] gasps oh my goodness they
got languages my baby six days old
already if I had one food forever it
might be Mexican Mexican or Italian yeah
one of those two if I could only have
one thing forever
like a specific ethnic food Mexicans so
good oh it's kind of know what I might
say Brazilian really made to say to
haast Korea if I had money short yeah I
wouldn't miss the meat yeah
dude all the carne asada with Mexican oh
that's true that's true yeah but like if
I'm if there's a Mexican joint next to a
Fogo de Chao I you know what I'm not
Bigfoot good a child guys stresses me
out
are you flip the green they just keep
coming I'm sweating and I don't you know
and I don't eat the salad bar and like
you ain't honeydicked me on that dude
that's how you keep your Oh digestive
tract clean that's about ever I know
I'll eat the filet the real expensive
one I'm like you know what I'm looking
for you look at my leg I'll do that I
forget what is the way to go I think
that's it roast yeah yeah it's real link
yeah well they bring the key or the
sausage I'm like [ __ ] I didn't come
here for sausage go get the [ __ ] red
meat bro
what's with the dried tomatoes I know
you're you could put away some food I
guarantee you Ari Shaffir will eat you
under the table in that place I agree I
don't eat that much food there's some
but you can if you want I could you
could you got a lot
room yeah you're a big fella bigger than
Ari Shaffir I'm telling you I never seen
nothing like it he just goes for plates
and plates all of us including Diaz it's
always the skinny guy sitting back home
what the [ __ ] is going what you want I'm
gonna keep eating so I think Ari when he
knows he's gonna go to Fogo to child he
like won't eat for like a day I think
Jew in a man he's just he just gangster
about it it's I think it's competitive
as well it's like Penn is fun you jerk
you think you got to make me pay this
much and I'm not gonna eat more than
that's worth did we uh we had Dan Soder
Anya hood the comic comic he's [ __ ]
the best he's forgot new HBO special
right yeah damn yeah he's from Aurora
did we played against John high school
[ __ ] what did he play he played a
linebacker
smoky hill I played at Overland so we
know each other that's hilarious yeah so
we had him on the show day but he was
talking about we're talking about how
the culture in LA the comics how they
like help each other out and I was like
well that's because Joe Rogan cat is the
guy that cultivated that kind of
atmosphere where you know it's we help
each other out in the podcast game in
the comics like Joe's only started that
and he goes you know who start in New
York and like I don't seen him in New
York I know you guys and Andrew Schultz
kind of part of the squad over here now
but and he goes when Ari moved from LA
because of Joe when I moved from LA came
to New York he came in there was like
[ __ ] wrong with you guys what's wrong
with you guys and just kind of like took
over I was like no no we're gonna help
each other out man and he's like that
and he learned that obviously you and I
are close but he took that same attitude
and brought to New York
[Applause]